each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
how many people were in the f-sharp
tutorial yesterday yesterday how many
weren't actually so how can we have a
good number who won that's good on I'm
not going to i'm not going to repeated
in general introduction to F sharp but
thank you for coming along to this this
district we have where I think it's
looking at that that Wolfram's talk is
was was amazing I mean they're the
toughest to do work just looks
absolutely fantastic on the on the cloud
data and devices I think not all talks
are addressing all of those elements or
did very different aspects of these
elements we have manual for beyond the
next session we'll be looking at the
diffuse web of just about the divided
programming devices in the context of
web programming in a very different way
my work is focusing on a very different
kind of problem which is about
addressing this issue about whether
programming I am going to take this off
not returns them this is too loud yeah
it's too loud too loud your janitor it's
too loved okay okay that's better thanks
ok
okay so this is this an Acura scan of
work its work that started with the
simple sorry this is a bit of the work
that started with looking at how to
integrate F shell F sharp with Excel
actually we have F sharp sitting
alongside of information rich
environment which is Excel and we want
the two to work together just in a sense
it's a form of hosting of you want a
host of programming language alongside a
data source in an application and then
we started to look at the applications
of the mechanisms we were starting to
build into F sharp and then we started
to think about well what are all the
other information rich contexts that
people work in there's intervene Oh
database programming is and information
rich context and we know are that there
are many kinds of other application
sources but then we started to look at
applications of this to web-based data
sources and then in a sense we started
to look to think that life today is very
as a life as a programmer is very much
hosted we live in a hosted world right
where we're hosting our programs against
the internet against the the web based
data sources and then when you look at
information rich programming in say an
enterprise context then people in the
enterprise today are hosting not just
against one database as they might have
been ten years ago but the hosting
against the whole information context
and enormously large information context
which they need to access through there
through their programming environments
so we need to change the fundamental
principle of what we're looking at here
is we need to very much change our
notion of what of a programming language
architecture to take into account that
the world that every single programming
language context that we work in is
information rich you know in a kind of
way that we haven't had to experience
before in a foundational level as we in
terms of programming language and
compiler and tool architecture and
design so the world is information rich
and all our program
are hosted against information context
and that means modern applications or
information rich juice as you can see
that from Wolfram's Wolfram sort of talk
there are languages and our libraries
are very information sparse and they I
think the fundamental thing I want to
get across in this talk is that our
languages need to include the mechanisms
to allow the projection of very large
and very sophisticated data sources into
the programming language context and I
want to so and if we don't have that
then we have a problem we have a loss of
programmer productivity through through
through that and so what we're doing an
f-sharp is putting in one particular
manifestation of a of a mechanism to
allow compart components to project in
information sources into the programming
language context and from a research
perspective this opens up it feels like
it's just the start of a discussion
about how programming languages should
interact with the Semantic Web how
programming with ontology how
programming languages should be changed
to instead of being so much of our
modern programming language design is
all about how do we tame in memory
objects how do we program with with
those objects we allocate on that in the
memory and we work with those but what
we're seeing is a shift towards the
programming language design has to be
thought of as a way of processing
information from external sources if you
look from link in particular in c-sharp
three-point oh and you see well what was
the shift that occurred there that means
suddenly a mainstream language had at
its core a mechanism about processing
information and sending queries and
everything else and it feels like we
just honor that as our languages
developed as a Haskell's as our scholars
as our F sharp sand out these these
general-purpose languages develop they
have to become information-rich
programming languages so sometimes this
can seem kind of magical it's not that
magical in fact it's a fairly simple
mechanism we're adding to F sharp three
photo collection type providers as I
said I think from the research
perspective
sunny the start of a discussion and we
can I'd like to touch on those themes
more towards the end and from the F
sharp perspective we see these two very
complementary technologies ago in your
c1 is type providers for bringing in the
names of all the data of all the data
sources and services in an information
context and link which is a way of
sending the queries back to those data
sources and Link is also a way of
publishing and packing it packaging on
new data sources and publishing
publishing them through various
protocols and together I kind of think
of what we're trying to do here is
making a language integrated data and
and services so this I use this example
in my tutorial I'll use it again because
it's a pretty good one I should say the
web connection here has been was slow
the other day much much lower than I had
had hoped but I'm hoping will be ok so
let's take a look at what I mean so in
this setting we've referenced a very
small set of you could think of them as
libraries but they're not like the first
one in particular is not the library as
we know it the others are just some some
scripting libraries I'm going to be
using along the way and the what we what
we've done here is reference one small
component which embeds f-sharp against
the an information source which is
enormous which actually this information
source in many ways if you see its
projected projection into the future in
particular but it's already a very very
large ontology of information with
excellent metadata information that this
is eNOS some close approximation you
know a first approximation of a 22 all
of human knowledge in the Wikipedia
sense of human knowledge what we've got
here is pretty much every for every page
in Wikipedia there's a corresponding
entry in this in this ontology in an
organized form of an organized form
which will develop over time I'm not
enjoy amusement parks tivat needs
have a top-level domain entry for the
various domains of information that have
been projected into the programming
language context here but the idea that
I want to get across is that imagine if
you were sitting down in your
general-purpose programming language and
you needed to get this information ok so
you for some reason and the example I
tend to use is the chemical elements but
we could be looking at all sorts of
other things like you want to know the
list of books in the world I mean at the
full list of books in the world okay if
you want to know our every if you want
to know if you're an astronomer a want
to know every asteroid in the world you
want to be working live against you know
the full set of at the full data bases
of astronomical information in your
programming language context now as
computer scientists we quite like to
live in rarified worlds where we don't
have that much information around okay
depends it depending on your field and
there's a parallel track here about mega
mega data and those guys are probably
you know thinking all the time about
about major data data sources but in the
programming languages world we we don't
want that many we're happy with well in
fact you know when we did F sharp 2
point 0 we were really happy that we had
all those dotnet libraries available we
had like tear a thousand types or
something or 50 libraries that we could
suddenly use to do all sorts of
interesting programming in this setting
we've now got hundreds of thousands of
types and millions of objects are
instances of facts or objects available
to us in our programming language
context and you have to imagine yourself
that you're not necessarily a computer
scientist who's a doesn't it need so
much information to do to do
publications and work but you are
computing but you're actually working as
an astronomer or you're working in one
of these information rich fields and how
easy can we make it to just get the
world's data the world
mation in the in the programming
language context so yet so if we go to
say chemistry and we look for the
chemical elements we can actually
evaluate those depending on how how
happy the web connection is with us it's
pretty pretty good so we have here the
the chemical element and the key thing
here is that we're not just working in a
in a dynamic language programming
environment although I'm doing some
interactive evaluation along the way its
yield here that we're working a strongly
type setting so that as I write a query
for a and each of the chemical elements
strongly typed as and very much nickel I
brought this out already in his talk
that the reason we're interested in
strong typing is not just about all the
software engineering properties but in
terms of the inference that's being done
over the program text yeah during as
during what we would call design time or
code editing time in in in in visual
studio i'm only in f-sharp talk so that
means we have type inference here which
means we get intel a sense it not only
means we get intellisense but it means
we get these definitions coming through
we can properly propagate metadata
information through about the data
sources that you're working with so when
you come to boiling point imagine if you
had to design this library this will
take a very very long time to design and
import that data from that external
source but what we're doing is changing
programming so that you just work with
these external ontologies they're just
there they're just part of the world in
which you work and program and live okay
so for example let's say you need as
part of your work information on the on
the list of languages in the world okay
then you would just come to web data and
you and it's quite a quiz many different
times in programming that you might need
the the list of languages then sure you
have the list of human languages and you
can just to get that and evaluate it you
have imaged data for those lang
images you have lots of property
information and you have even a
definition here for what is a human
language and once you have that set of
human and well interestingly for these
human languages if we take the the first
one you can use head Hearns and have a
look at its properties then these the
world of the Semantic Web has done the
work force of even relating these two
particular you know the key identifies
that allow us to relate these languages
through two other ontology Xin to other
services so we're not locked into the 11
view of the world here we have the key
the key links in the key piece of data
here to be working with other other
kinds of data as well and so they've
done a very good job of organizing the
properties and the relationships between
this data now something I'd like to
emphasize here is that this data is
incredibly interlinked so let's take one
example of that so I in terms of the the
so I take the chemistry take the
chemical elements or take the head one
and then we talk about the discoverer
here run through this and we discover
there could be multiple discoverers so
we get the first discover and we get say
the the I sorry the discovering country
here and we get the the first element
and we get now it's a country so we've
gone from chemistry through to
information about about countries where
suddenly in a completely different part
and a completely different part of the
world of the web buzz of the Semantic
Web of information and this is this goes
against many of our instincts as library
designers if we've started to design a
library for chemical elements you
wouldn't think that you would end up
designing a library of getting through
links through two countries and
currencies and forms of government and
all the other relations their currencies
of other countries have always had but
the if we take a semantic web view of
information and then a the right
programming language view about getting
that information into the programming
language context
and we make sure we have the right
elements in our language like a good dot
notation and tell us and everything then
it's clear that this is actually very
very useful to have these relations if
you are building a que historical
chemistry application to display the
people and the countries who displayed
to school students for example then yeah
I mean maybe the calling code isn't
actually the interesting thing about
their the country but then there will be
other forms our deeds is quite
reasonable if it's a historical
application to say what was the form of
government at the time the chemical
element was discovered and what sort of
scientific community was there and so on
you might be interested in getting that
kind of information across to your to
your students so the information is
useful in application development and in
information-rich application development
and the relations are useful and the
interlinking of the Semantic Web is
unbelievable now the key thing from the
programming language perspective here is
that we are we're using an open
architecture and this this particular
ontology or this particular piece of
web-based data is just one example of
what you can project into the
programming language context we're not
tying f-sharp to any particular kind of
data not even to any particular format
for data the world of big data on the
web and in enterprises like the Wild
West okay every day someone's coming up
with a new format people are rolling
into town and setting up camp and like
and running other people out of town and
yeah everything's changing every single
every single week almost is in different
kind of standards and initiatives and
Google's got a lot of things going on
Microsoft has a lot of things going on
and so we have to have architectures in
our programming languages that are going
to last the next 10 or 20 years to to
allow us to live in a world where all
these where the information base is
changing so we have an open architecture
where we can predict in web data and
different and many different kinds of
data through adapter components it's in
many ways not a surprising architecture
what's the most surprising thing is just
how amazingly useful this architecture
is just to give you a feeling for the
kind of dotnet code you would have to
write to get strongly typed
use of this of this particular ontology
the underlying API for this ontology is
free base comm with some JSON API where
you have to start giving HTTP strings
and the data eventually comes back you
could type this string into your browser
and you could get the data that we're
seeing it's just would be incredibly
clunky to do it and then you have to
pass it into the strongly typed record
fields and you end up writing code like
this I mean this if you draw the
spectrum of programmer skills all right
this is way down at the right hand end
right of a program this have to be very
good to put together these elements to
even get any data into a strongly typed
programming language and this is a
pretty the full-featured programming
language that by today's standards it's
actually very good but for doing this
kind of work but we have to make this
vastly simpler and what we're doing when
all you have to do is go web data doc
chemistry or chemical elements to access
that data source and we've pulled that
all the way back to the other end of the
programming language spectrum and made
it I think literally a thousand times
easier to be able to get your to be able
to work with this particular with the
this particular data source and there's
a particularly interesting application
because the size of this application is
thousands and thousands of types of
information in that web ontology and we
need an architecture which will scale to
that kind of type exact about that kind
of that kind of data so the the magic
we're doing is is just changing our
notion of what of what is compiler
architecture that we're going to use a
plug-in notion and a extent so there's
many many different ways you can rip
apart programming language
implementations and with plug various
things in and what I think is special
about this is that we found one
particular point which is just just to
adapt name resolution and the notion of
library importing what is a library
we're saying a library is not just a
library as in our dll or some physical
bits on on disk a library is a logical
component which can project in arbitrary
information sources which for the
purposes of many with the schemas of
these external information sources are
sufficiently constant that for most
infant for most purposes
that we can accept there's a trade-off
here we obviously losing some static
typing in a sense losing some is losing
some strong typing guarantees because
the schemers of these things can change
the service can disappear right and
suddenly your program like doesn't
really type check anymore it doesn't or
at least doesn't run correctly so we're
trading off a little bit in terms of the
programmer has to manage to that
relationship with the schema change in
the database and in turn we're exploding
the amount of information that is
available to the to the programmer so
these components are relatively small
are they that you reference them as you
would any other component except they're
just projecting a logical space of types
and potentially infinite space of types
you can think of it as being a lazily
explored space of types if you like
they're all nominal types is the strong
emphasis on nominal types rather than
using structural types but that is that
works fine I mean part of the lesson of
this I think is that nominal types are
really a good way for representing real
world entities and they're at least well
I think that's one of the research
questions is okay if we change our
notion of what the type system is for
and it's for representing this kind of
stuff then what relationships do we want
between types is going to be a lot of
familiarity in that what suddenly the
role of things like security types
becomes vastly more important so the the
role of things like units of measure
becomes vastly more important because
suddenly all these data sources really
do come attached with units of measure
in their descriptions and so I think
this changes how we think about type
systems and programming languages is a
question of granularity what's the right
let you know to lend the type system
suddenly you realize use it for some
applications you really want like just
an arbitrary notion of an ontology
object a triple or something to some
applications you want much more fun
refined grain notions of typing and
actually probably want multiple views of
the same data source and this and this
kind of setting can cope with that you
can have the programmers select between
the various possible views of the data
source do you look at an Excel table as
individual cells do you look at it as a
rose by named column what's your you've
got multiple views over the same
information sources okay so just to say
these components are very small so these
pits two instances of type providers are
in the order of like maybe they're like
a thousand lines of code or between one
hundred or thousand lines of code
they're not big components to a far as
adapter so type providers a design time
component that provides a computed space
of types of methods you think of it just
as a compiler an idea extension that's
fine if you want to think of it in
pragmatic terms and adapt it between
data services and end on that languages
the API is incredibly small i love this
api because this is the static semantics
here of there these days it says give us
a sufficiently rich type description in
the middle of given a name you can
ignore this this second one we've
actually removed that and this is the
runtime semantics this is so this is a
static semantics for the world all the
world's information sources go bang
through this particular description and
then this is runtime semantics so how to
access all those information sources
comes gets dropped in through here too
so give us enough meta information and
then we reverse compile that matter that
meta information down into code in in
the f sharp in when we're actually
running F sharp code so they're not big
to implement in a map information
sources into the dotnet type system they
do require a bit of skill to implement a
type provider because you have to be
sufficiently good at thinking about
object relational mapping zor schemas
and your vision type based programming
and so on but we wouldn't expect
everybody just for writing a type
provider but there it would be not too
hard to do them ok the so people today
mediate between their program and all
these data sources by doing oodles of
code generation they just like Microsoft
as loves code generation tools if you go
to visual studio half of Visual Studio
actually really it's interesting to look
at visual studio and those kind of idea
environments really half of those
environments are all about mediating
with external source of information
you've got your server Explorer on your
right Enosh sharepoint server and then
your data data schema designer and all
sorts of other bits and pieces just to
kind of work with those external data
sources and much of this actually one
reason why we're doing this in f-sharp
is because F sharp actually has a
trouble inside Microsoft and being able
to play catch up with all that fancy
tooling which is actually
incredibly expensive to build all those
click click click things and we have to
by putting in a very general mechanism
and an adapter architecture then we can
open that up to the community to build
these adapter components and we don't
have to play catch-up with with with the
modern with all those designer
components and cogeneration has all
sorts of problems in practice it's just
like you see you just see the mess that
programmers get into when they take
thick to generate a code and they start
editing it and adapting it and checking
it in and it's just it's just
unbelievable what a mess modern software
engineering becomes because of
cogeneration so to show one more example
of this and then I wrap up and hand over
to Manuel the this this example is a is
the Microsoft as windows as you a
marketplace data market it's it's as I
say it's a one-stop shop for data and
you can it's meant to be a place where
you can host a data on the web but they
also host it's about professionalization
of the hosting of data so when you sign
up for your sign in with your Twitter
Facebook or whatever your live ID at the
top and you are and you acquire a data
set you get the rights to access the
data set you get a contract that the
schemer of that data set won't change
for a year and it will be available for
a year okay out of it and there maybe
you get the first fifty thousand queries
a month free and then you start to pay
money after after that or something
there's some kind of payment arrangement
and so that's all about
professionalisation there's there's a
it's a way to pay for your money and pay
for your data there's a way to it's just
a usual marketplace kind of kind of
thing so in this sample we take a small
type provider for the data market
and once you have the the type provider
the the idea of the tie providers you're
always designing a data space of some
kind and in this data space the idea is
that you walk to Windows Azure and you
say what does windows as you have it has
it has a market place among other things
what's in the marketplace you go over
and you see there's a there's a there's
various shops and one of them is there
is a data market here they say well what
are they selling at the data market and
not too surprisingly on the tables they
have data sets okay and so what data
sets do they have okay we're not just
dealing with one with one data source
now we're dealing with many different
data sources and and things like that
the data market start to aggregate many
different kinds of data as well as this
game going on that everybody who
publishes data is also becoming a way of
aggregating arbitrary feeds of data so
if you look at SharePoint suddenly you
can aggregate all sorts of things in
through SharePoint if you look at google
data sources i think you can do the same
or freebase starts to aggregate all the
world's information sort of through that
so there's many different people trying
as i said it's a wild west in a way but
this as you can see we start to upgrade
all sorts of professional data sets into
the data market so if we go to for
instance 22 statistics here then we get
some of the big major free and open data
sets we have crime statistics or
greenhouse gas emissions or this FAO
Food and Agriculture data and I happened
to be in the airport and I met someone
who works for the FAO as a veteran
veterinary epidemiologist and I said I
really work for their favor I don't and
so have a look at this and I know typed
in this at a press dot and she just
could not believe that the data that she
worked with every single day was
available so easily in this an immediate
of charting with it and so on that she
so easily in a in a programming language
context suddenly your programming
language becomes relevant to all sorts
of other people's work that it was never
real particularly relevant to before or
as I the stretch of the imagination to
your you'd always be predicated off only
we had the FAO data then the programming
language would be useful for 4 from for
my work so to take a fairly negative one
will actually look at the the crime data
and then
satyrs happen to be the first on the
list so it's so it's what I did you have
to do a little bit more work on these
examples but we can start to just query
the the crime data for 2006 2008 we can
start to query it here so for instance
we can take the crime data where the
population is not zero the violent crime
is above a certain level amadou city and
violent crime you'll notice that these
are all cities in Alaska because the
default for this data provider is to
provide the first hundred elements of as
data set and they come out as all being
in Alaska by default which is not good
so we actually want to be able to have
linked queries that we send to the
database the filter on the database and
then project out a smaller part of that
and that doesn't happen automatically at
the above this if you use this new
feature of F sharp which is putting link
queries into F sharp we have a query sub
language where for each of the elements
in the crime data we can say we won New
York in 2007 and then once we have that
this is what we're allowed to run on the
server we can do some post filtering on
the client which is this part here some
additional where clauses and selections
here so for you if we run that then
we'll be getting rd the top crime the
the the cities with the highest crime
statistics in in New York in 2007 okay
so just to say this has many many
applications we pull the sir
applications to information sources on
the local machine is a surprising one
that this is on every single PC or Mac
or anything there's a huge amount of
schema ties information which is a
cording to management standards for when
these things that managed by
professional people are networks and if
you want to know for instance what are
the let's take a look what you get down
here if you want to know what your what
your devices are your your your
installed elements of software or the
batteries on your pc or you want to say
imagine you're a system administrator
and you want to write a script which is
going to run on your machine we're going
to interrogate
every machine on your network to find a
particular battery or particular device
driver with a particular ID
co-production ID code because you know
those don't those are faulty okay and
you want to take those out before they
burn your laptops or something then you
can use this kind of programming to be
to be just immediately finding those
elements that you want in your
information your enterprise information
rich context and then be writing your
script and off you go and this is so
much easier than other ways of
interrogating and accessing information
in that enterprise context okay so I
think I'm wind up so so the AV is are we
we start to do some other things that
Microsoft of involved in a standard
called o data it's a little bit like G
later or other things it's like a weak
form of relational data for the for the
for the web streaming data it's quite
this good and I it's and you can it
would have the next version of F sharp
you'll just be able to give a URL here
which is the service you're connecting
to and start doing strongly type
programming directly against the service
similarly with a sequel connection all
you have to do is give a connection
string to the database and you'll be
able to start using the database tables
immediately and interestingly a
Microsoft it turns out that like five
percent of the world's programmers now
of five to ten percent I mean it depends
on how you measure it are actually
SharePoint programmers the SharePoint is
one of the fastest growing products at
Microsoft and it's being very very
successful in inside enterprises and so
the ability just to point to a
SharePoint site and get always list of
information that is being shared
collaborate collaboratively between your
teams is a very interesting application
and I think that leads so I'll skip skip
the query Parker's you've seen those
that leads to other interesting many men
using data sources we could projecting
me of web data data markets management
information spreadsheets web services
are this CRM data sort of enterprise
resource planning data and interesting
error we haven't explored yet but is a
modern
theme is of social data what happens
when you work with with with maybe
Facebook but or maybe more open open
versions of social data and more
pragmatic ones like sequel and xml so
the that's the vision is to be working
with these data sources strongly-typed
without explicit cogent and extensible
and open way so our mantra is the
world's information rich and our
languages need to be information rich
too and so the future is of what we're
doing with f is the summation from us to
not throw the baby out with the
bathwater and have to move to a
dynamically typed language or dome and a
dynamically typed programming in order
to solve this problem to allow us to
keep strong typing and just sort of
break down the walls between the
programming language and these external
data sources okay so there's some books
on up shop and I think that's what I
wants to say and do we have questions
and then soon hand over to memo do want
to come